[Music]
this nightmare begins
in a town very much like your own
you can smell the welcoming scent of
bacon
that your neighbor is frying for their
morning meal here the wind
rustles through leaves of trees aligning
roads that lead to a mass of
distant life power of engines and
laughter of children
all living their day-to-day lives
you can see the silhouettes of rooftops
that encircle you
as the sun begins to rise from the
distance
leaving an auburn glow to beam upon the
tiled bricks
of your home's walls as you feel the
familiar chill
of a winter morning but as normal as
this all sounds
an abnormal air lingers within the scene
although the town sounds smells and
seems alive
with all senses pointing to a conclusion
of comfort
you notice one pivotal difference
no physical signs of life exist
the town is completely deserted
in that moment of realization you're
surprised by the outline
of a figure stepping out from around a
darkened corner
you correct yourself almost
completely deserted the figure is that
of a man as he emerges from the shadows
you can make out his exasperated
expression spotlight
by the morning sun's glow his forehead
crinkles
as his deep brown eyes dart from left to
right
and his aged fingers trace the brick
wall the street opposite yours
he does not seem to notice your presence
as he marches onward
through your line of sight his movements
are a mixture of confused defiance
giving off the impression that he's late
to an important event
that he's not quite sure the destination
of
seeing another presence would normally
ease and nun nerve soul
but nothing about this man is calming in
fact
agonizing stress seems to exude from him
like a bad stench
clouding your vision as he grows closer
forcing its way unwillingly up your
nostrils
you gag on the smell of what you could
have sworn to be decaying
flesh and drastically wipe your bleary
eyes to double check that the man is not
hurt or bleeding
to your surprise he's perfectly well
kept
with the exception of anxiety-induced
sweat which has stained his armpits and
beaded upon a creased brow
there are no physical signs that this
man is in pain
even so you feel the atmosphere becoming
heavy
as the man draws nearer as if burdened
by some dark grief that has manifested
itself into the form
of rolling mist with every step the man
takes
the winter morning twists and turns into
a much more disturbing scene
browned orange beams of light probe
through the mist as it engulfs you
warping the rustling of the nearby trees
into a distant howl
low and mourning it's only now that you
realize
that the stench which has become near
unbearable
is not that of the man but of the bacon
that was
only moments ago pleasant enough to make
your stomach rumble
the thought of eating becomes unpleasant
as you wretch
trying not to think of what rancid flesh
could be decaying nearby
but this is not enough to deter your
curiosity
through the mist the man remains
outlined in rays of the morning sun
a glowing spectacle on a desaturated
stage
his back turns to you as he quickens his
pace
down the street you follow
as you walk you're greeted with familiar
yet disturbed sights
through spirals of the mist that follows
you cars that you've come to know
throughout your daily commute
lay skewed and riddled with dust as you
pass you can still make out the imprints
of forgotten passengers
looking to the sky you notice signs of
life
as birds soar beyond the thick fog
you squint and feel your heart fall to
the pit of your stomach
as you realize the silhouettes are in
fact flying
upside down through the haze you can
almost make out their beady eyes
rolling to the back of their heads
following you while they fly past
shuddering at that thought you bring
your attention back to the man in front
of you and begin to question
his presence unlike you the man does not
show any distaste for the sights and
smells that surround him
he's too focused to be distracted by
such things
his stride has now developed into a more
confident pace
tracing the faded markings in the center
of a cracked road
your gaze burns into the back of his
skull watching as his scruffy mess of
hair gets pulled by a dank frog that
swirls in and out of the rays of light
holding him within their grasp without
needing to speak
you see his dreaded urgency as clear as
day
but you are yet to understand its cause
this will not last long
as you press further ahead you notice a
bridge forming through the mist
and observe how the cracks from the road
beneath run deeply through it
the bridge appears as if it's about to
collapse at any moment
you assume this is why the man has
suddenly stopped in his tracks and
cautiously wait for him to turn around
confronting you to retrace his steps
however
this does not happen and you find
yourself silently waiting for what feels
like an eternity
as your own brow builds up beads of
nervous sweat
mimicking that of the man in front of
you
his breath has become shallow his eyes
fix directly
in front of him following the man's gaze
you make out a shadow
at the end of the bridge buried deep
beneath the mass of fog
yet faintly illuminated by an ember
light
your heart thuds deep within your chest
as you fight the urge to make your
presence known by screaming out to the
figure about the fragile state of the
bridge
all sense of safety had wafted away with
that fresh smell of bacon
replacing it with a crippling anxiety
but
not for your own sake for some reason
you know that this fog of doom was never
meant for you you're just an unfortunate
bystander
with feet rooted to the spot in shock
your vision is slowly welcomed through
the mist
teasing you as it coils and caresses its
way around the figure to form a dramatic
entrance
the shape that finally emerges leaves
you unable to hold back a gas with
rotten air
leaving you choking while you take in
the sight forming before your eyes
the sight of a woman her frail body
leads little to the imagination as a
thin gown
flails to cover whatever carves might
remain amongst the protruding bones
tearing against her tyson's skin even
from such a distance
blue veins are easily visible spreading
like
branches throughout her almost
translucently pale complexion
but this is not the reason why you're
unable to let out the trapped breath of
stale air you had gasped
your eyes fixate on the woman's skull in
morbid fascination
and utter disbelief you can tell that
the woman had once been a thing of
beauty
with bright green eyes that reflect the
morning rays of light
these eyes which stare hopelessly at the
man whose gaze is locked within them
her lips have been painted red in a vain
attempt to inject some colour into her
porcelain body
but those days of beauty were long gone
as your attention is drawn towards the
woman's skull
a skull that soars abnormally upwards
crushed by an
unsympathetic force as if someone had
taken a rolling pin
and smeared the woman's skull skyward
this bare skull mimics the cracks in the
road beneath her
revealing deep pink flesh between her
tears of skin
you can only assume that this is the
remnants of her brain
but you hope not to see this in any
finer detail
coarse strands of hair shoot awkwardly
out of the cracked skull
twisting and turning with the winding
wind surrounding her
a dim blue light pulsates to the woman's
left
distracting you as your gaze escapes to
locate its source
you're greeted with a nod sight
the woman's veins throb in time with
this light
as your eyes trace a bag of questionable
liquid
that bubbles within an iv drip attached
to a steel frame
being held up by the woman's skeletal
hands
you follow a liquid bubble flow from the
bag
down a winding tube leading to a large
needle
that has become encrusted within the
crease of her arm
it looks as though the skin has become
adjusted to the needle's presence
with fine layers of fresh skin having
grown around the dried up crust of
liquid
that seeps from within you watch in all
as this liquid emits a ghostly glow
pumping through her veins you wonder if
this is the only thing
keeping this frail remnant of a woman
alive
if this is what you can call alive she
looks more like an aberration
with her eyes locked unblinking and her
body looking as if it's about to shatter
and fade away with the harsh myth
sweeping about her
the only signs of life show within her
shallow breaths
when her skin stretches even more so as
to sink within the darkened crevices
of her skeletal frame you wait for her
to speak
she does not you wait for her to move
she does not you wait for her to lose
her grip on the drip
and succumb to her inevitable death over
the cracked ground beneath her to
crumble and eat her
hole neither of these things happen
but still you wait you're startled
by a low mutter reaching your ears which
draws your attention away from
the scene at the end of the bridge
blinking you allow your eyes to tear
their gaze and follow the source of the
sound to see that the man in front of
you
has begun to speak but he's not speaking
to you
nor to the woman the words overlap each
other in a hushed tone
and a quick pace but you squint to make
out his quivering lips
i did this he seemed to repeat
but surely you must be mistaken how can
this man
feel responsible for the state of this
woman does he know her
however after further speculation
you're certain that these words are
correct i did this
i did this i did this
eventually the muttering suffices taking
in a deep breath
of muggy air he clears his throat so
that he can project his last words
clearly forgive me this
unlocks a dormant source of life within
the woman
as soon as the words had left the man's
lips her eyes once dull and sun
constrained to focus on her target
fixating on the man in front of her the
blue liquid
pumping throughout her body shines
through the mist surrounding her as
she's propelled forward
at an alarming rate it almost seems as
she's hovering just above the ground
at the speed of which she cuts through
the dense mist
you're unsure how a woman who moments
ago seemed at death's door
could move in such a manner the man had
a mere second to react
managing to stumble a few steps
backwards in panic
placing him parallel to you before
succumbing to the morbidly fascinating
sight that you're unable to escape from
you watch as her body rushes past yours
and panic causes time to slow enough for
you to pinpoint every detail
of this horrifying scene the woman's
bulging eyes
protruding outwards from her crushed
skull as her mouth opens to let out an
agonizing whale
while the man's stare quivers under the
impending pressure of her overwhelming
presence
those teeth that remained were misplaced
and
almost animalistic hanging from her
gaping hole of a mouth
like stained daggers you notice spit
splutter outwards from them through her
unintelligible cries
it is an utterly terrifying view
however even through fear
you can't help but feel something
irrevocably sad
about this scene the man's sunken eyes
now wet from self-pity close tight in
defeat
as his arms spread wide to embrace the
mess that he is so adamant to have
caused
his fingertips stretched towards the
monstrous form that weeps before him
veins throbbing skin tearing eyes
carving
into his soul until all of a sudden
the sight vanishes completely
hearing a thud you see the man fall to
his knees while letting out audible
cries of his own
howling from deep within his chest
all the while his arms remain
outstretched to cradle a figure that no
longer holds his attention
you stare in bewilderment for a moment
replaying the last few moments in your
head for any sense of what just happened
you see the woman draw nearer to the
man's solemn face
you see her stretch skull skew backwards
against the pressure of the wind
ripping against her fast moving body you
see her hand
grip the uv drip that glides next to her
your eyes awaken from their delirious
gaze alerted
to the sudden realization that for a
moment
the uv drip was all you could see as the
woman's body had moved steadily parallel
to yours
you recall how her body shrunk as a
horrific side profile was revealed
horrific because simply put
there was no side profile her skin and
bones
her flesh and vein riddled skin
[Music]
everything had shriveled to complete
absence
armed with this new knowledge unsafety
pricks
at your spine tempting you to shift it
anxiously to peer back upon the street
that you just walked down
you do as your instincts tell you sure
enough
your suspicions are correct you and the
man are not alone
the woman or more the remnants of a
woman
shift slowly over the cracks in the road
you watch the back of her protruding
skull bob intermittently
revealing flashy pockets with every
shift of her weight
she doesn't look your way she doesn't
fall to her movements
she doesn't let out that same ear
piercing shriek that rings in your head
from moments ago
she doesn't make a sound at all how did
this woman
come to be this way what hardships
did she have to endure what possible
purpose
could her life now hold endless
questions
burden your mind as she becomes nothing
more than a figure
through the mist once more any hope of
understanding or reason
fading along with it this woman
is not yours to help her story
is not yours to know you're just another
shadow
peering through the fog of a stranger's
nightmare
an emptiness washes over you as her
silhouette starts to disappear
leaving you alone with only the sounds
of a broken man
forgive me forgive me
forgive me forgive me
forgive me forgive me
forgive me
[Music]
you